dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr. Caruso life ahead in the
last few years we have seen a bunch of
new AI based techniques that were
specialized in generating new and novel
images this is mainly done through
learning based techniques typically a
generative adversarial Network again in
short which is an architecture where a
generator neural network creates new
images and passes it to a discriminator
network which learns to distinguish real
photos from these fake generated images
the two networks who learn and improve
together and generate better and better
images over time what you see here is a
set of results created with a technique
by the name psycho Gann this could even
translate daytime into nighttime images
reimagine the picture of a horse as if
it were a zebra and more
we can also use it for star transfer a
problem where we have two input images
one for content and one for style and as
you see here the output would be a nice
mixture of the two however if we use
cycle Gann for this kind of star
transfer we'll get something like this
the goal was to learn the style of a
select set of famous illustrators of
children's books by providing an input
image with their work so what do you
think about the results well the style
is indeed completely different from the
source but the algorithm seems a little
too heavy-handed and did not leave the
content itself intact
let's have a look at another result with
a previous technique maybe this will do
better this is due again which refers to
a paper by the name and supervised duel
learning for image to image translation
this uses two Gans to perform image
translation where one can learns to
translate for instance from day to night
while the other learns the opposite
night to day translation this among
other advantages makes things very
efficient but as you see here in these
cases it preserves the content of the
image but perhaps a little too much
because the style itself does not appear
too prominently in the output images so
cycle Gong is good at transferring style
but a little less so for content and do
again is good at preserving the content
but sometimes adds too little of the
style to the image and now hold on to
your papers because this new technique
by the name Gunilla offers us these
results
the content is intact checkmark and the
style goes through really well checkmark
it preserves the content and transfers
the style at the same time excellent one
of the many key reasons as to why this
happens is the usage of skip connections
which help preserve the content
information as we travel deeper into the
neural network so finally let's put our
money where our mouth is and take a
bunch of illustrators marvel at their
unique style and then apply to
photographs and see how the algorithm
stacks up against other previous works
Wow I love these beautiful results these
comparisons really show how good the new
Gunilla technique is at preserving
content and note that these are distinct
artistic styles that are really
difficult to reproduce even for humans
it is truly amazing that we can perform
such a thing algorithmically don't
forget that the first star transfer
paper appeared approximately three to
three and a half years ago and now we
have come a long long way the pace of
progress in machine learning research is
truly stunning while we are looking at
some more amazing results this time
around only from Gunilla I will note
that the authors also made a user study
with 48 people who favored this against
previous techniques
and perhaps leaving the best for last it
even draw in the style of Hayao Miyazaki
I bet there are a bunch of Miyazaki fans
watching so let me know in the comments
what you think about these results what
a time to be alive this episode has been
supported by weights and biases in this
post they show you how to easily iterate
on models by visualizing and comparing
experiments in real time also weights
and biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning
projects their system is designed to
save you a ton of time and money and it
is actively used in projects at
prestigious labs such as open AI Toyota
research github and more and the best
part is that if you are an academic or
have an open-source project you can use
their tools for free it really is as
good as it gets
make sure to visit them through w and
b.com slash papers or just click the
link in the video description and you
can get a free demo today
our thanks to weights and biases for
their long-standing support and for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time